I was closeted for most of my life,
my adult life.
I wanted to be an actor,
which alone just that alone was,
um,
some people thought a crazy aspiration
to have because I am Asian and Asians,
uh,
first of all,
our adult have many opportunities to get
cast.
Plus the fact that,
um,
uh,
there were stereotypes that we were
saddled with either the cold,
heartless,
a killer,
uh,
the,
inscrutable a person that's got
something always going on in the back of
his mind leading to suspicion that a
where we could be spies or the survival,
the quiet obsequious or the buffoon,
all very unattractive stereotypes.
So why I would go into acting,
but something that,
well,
I'm the black sheep of the family.
My parents thought it was absolutely
crazy,
but they knew how passionate I was.
And to get cast with first,
uh,
this uh,
ethnic,
uh,
barrier,
a hurdle for me to cross A.
I didn't want to add another one of
being gay gay people.
We're not a cast or if they were exposed
as gay,
their career is faded.
I remember when I was a teenager,
there was a very good looking,
handsome actor named Tab Hunter who was
a contract active with warner brothers
and almost every other movie coming from
Warner Brothers start tab hunter.
He was the heartthrob of America until
confidential,
exposed him as being gay and eventually
he disappeared.
That was an object lesson for me and so
I was closeted and my career was making
progress and so I did everything to
protect my career,
which meant having my guard up all the
time.
Being careful about the pronouns I used,
a denying some,
a good portion of who I was.
It was a very uncomfortable,
a way to live,
except when you're doing it,
it becomes a part of your normal
existence.
I lived that uncomfortable existence as
what I thought was going to be my life.
You know,
I used to go to gay bars in Los Angeles
back then and,
uh,
it was a wonderful place.
That guard can come down.
I could make friends as who I am,
and to really relax and enjoy
friendship,
camaraderie,
and a,
a wonderful evening or an afternoon.
But one of the older people told me that
periodically the police would raid gay
bars and they would march the clients
out,
put them on a patty wagon,
drive them to the police station,
fingerprint them,
photograph them,
and their names were,
would be put on a list.
It was terrifying.
Their lives can be destroyed.
They could lose their jobs,
perhaps their families.
It was a horrible thing.
And what were they doing?
A criminal activity according to the law
at that time being gay was criminalized.
We were marched out,
put into paddy wagons and registered.
And I thought,
that's no different.
Different than what happened to me when
I was child because of this face,
because we look like the people that
bombed Pearl Harbor.
We were put into prison camps,
guarded over by,
uh,
soldiers with machine guns pointed down
that is from century towers.
It was the same thing.
And I thought that was horrible,
was wrong,
unjust.
And yet that was the way we had to live
those few isolated moments when we could
be ourselves.
And then stonewall happened.
When the people they're resistant,
they decided they had enough.
They're not going to take it anymore,
and that was the galvanizing event and
society began to change,
and by the 21st century,
uh,
things were really starting to change.
Massachusetts,
the State Supreme Court of Massachusetts
ruled that marriage equality was
constitutional.
So that was the first state.
Two years later on the other coast in
California,
the People's representatives this time,
through the legislative route,
both houses of the California
legislature,
the assembly and the Senate,
passed the marriage equality bill.
All that,
that bill needed was a signature of the
governor to become the law of the state.
It would have been two states book
ending America with marriage equality.
The governor at that time happened to be
a movie star,
Arnold Schwartzenegger.
When he campaigned for that office,
he told the public,
I'm from Hollywood.
I've worked with gays and lesbians.
Some of my best friends are gays and
lesbians,
and persuaded by that,
a couple of my gay friends did vote for
him.
Yet when that bill landed on his desk,
he acted as the representative of this
base,
the right wing of the Republican Party.
And he vetoed it.
I was raging,
but I had trained my body muscular,
holding that rage and that night brad
and I were watching the late night news
and I saw all these young people pouring
out on the Santa Monica Boulevard,
venting their rage on our no
Schwartzenegger and we felt the same way
and it got us to thinking and talking
and Brad and I discussed it.
I was 68 years old by that time and I
thought,
well,
I want my life to have some meeting.
I want the time that I have left to do
something about that aspect of who we
are.
And so I spoke to the press for the
first time as a gay man and I blasted
Arnold Schwarzenegger's veto and what I
thought of my career,
I thought it was going to go on the
downhill side.
The opposite happened.
It just lost and I've been working more
since coming out then I had been when I
was closeted.